good morning Nick it's tuesday I am home
home is a nice place to be
I missed you slightly off-white
bookshelf and you Dutch nerdfighter
shoes and I even missed you probably
Mouse poop so we got really liked your
video about the Renaissance in
circumstance and as I've been rereading
behind the beautiful forevers for the
nerdfighter book club by the way
nerdfighters don't forget to read this
book by June 10th anyway but thinking a
lot about luck and deserving what
happens to you probably in part because
I feel especially undeserving with good
reason of all the nice things that are
happening to me right now like any
people keep congratulating me after they
see The Fault in Our Stars movie as if I
did anything but all I did was get lucky
lucky that the book was published so
well lucky to have a great cover lucky
to the people I sold the movie rights to
happened to be brilliant lucky that the
wonderful cast and crew and director
came together to make a great movie I
mean hey guy didn't make savvy decisions
in this process or anything that just
got lucky there are much much better
books that have been made into terrible
terrible movies so Hank of course the
look was further back than that because
I'm lucky to have you as a brother and
collaborator unlucky than in 2007 you
wrote a great song about Harry Potter
that gave us a whole new audience I
happened to be born into a rich country
and I happened to be born male and white
and a culture that privileges maleness
and whiteness and I write in English ank
which is a massive advantage I mean why
a writer's writing in Latvian even those
far more talented than I am rarely fine
broad audiences I think all this fall in
Our Stars movie stuff is not happening
because I am a good person that's not
the way the world works and I hope I can
remember that because when you start to
think that the good things that have
happened to you have happened because
you worked harder than other people or
because the universe prefers you you
start to see the world with this weird
self-centered myopia and you don't
commit yourself to lessening inequality
or to supporting marginalized voices
because you don't think there's a
problem you start to think that the
world is as it should be now obviously
this is very bad for other people but I
think ultimately it's also bad for you I
don't mean you in particular like you're
a very nice person I mean like the
hypothetical you because there will come
a day when awful and unjust things
happen to you and if you believe that
you deserve the good things because you
were oh so good does that mean that you
now deserve the bad things I would argue
that in addition to not deserving all of
the wonderful things that happen in life
we don't deserve all of the terrible
things like Hank you don't deserve to
have ulcerative colitis that's not fair
no one deserves chronic pain or dementia
or poverty it's almost like deserving
isn't the best way to imagine it so like
I keep meaning to mention this but over
at crash course we're about to teach a
10-episode series in big history
this is
because of a grant from one of Bill
Gates's organizations basically we get
to chart the history of the universe
from the Big Bang to like now and I
bring this up because in big history
regarding that 99.9% of matter in the
solar system was sucked up by the Sun as
it formed everything else Jupiter the
Atlantic Ocean my astonishingly diverse
collection of polo shirts the probable
Mouse poop all of that is the point one
percent in that context everything in
the solar system not burning inside the
Sun is on the very far edge of the good
fortune bell curve to me at least think
it's not about deserving anything
because you are not your luck
no matter your circumstances you are
valuable and rare and worthy of love and
the great thing about humans my favorite
thing about humans actually is that we
can work together to improve each
other's chances of having healthy and
productive lives and whether it's cancer
research of the project for awesome or
being kind to a stranger at Walmart for
me that is the only real path to
gratitude and I know that I'm saying
this from an extremely privileged
position but I really believe that
gratitude is the proper response for the
absolute astonishment of getting to be
alive and aware and an essential part of
this crazy sprawling story in short Hank
I am very grateful to you and to all of
nerdfighteria hey I want to tell you
about two books I really like I know
that you're busy reading behind the
beautiful forevers but everything leads
to you by Nina Lacour and the great
green heist by Varion Johnson both
excellent now I'm going to try to go
track down that Mouse Hank I'll see you
on Friday